[موسيقى]
بريطانيا والعالم على موعد مع معركه
قضائيه شرسه بين الامير هاري ووسائل اعلام
بريطانيه يلومها بالتدخل بحياته الخاصه
وافساد العديد من علاقاته الشخصيه
والعائليه يعود هذه خلال الاسابيع المقبله
الى لندن ليكون اول فرد من افراد العائله
الملكيه الذي يدلي بافاده امام محكمه
قضائيه
حروب الامير المشاغب المتواصله كانت بدات
مع عائلته والان مع مجموعه صحفي مرر معركه
هاري مع الاعلام ليست جديده فهو عبر مرارا
عن رغبته في اصلاح صحافه التابلت في بلاده
اذ يعتبرها سببا في ماساه والدته الاميره
ديانا ومتوا في تشويه صوره زوجته ومشاركه
في تفاقم ازمته مع العائله
رفع وزوجته ماجن ما لا يقل عن سبع دعاوى
قضائيه ضد مؤسسات اعلاميه منذ عام 2019
بسبب انتهاكات للخصوصيه
خصوصيه ساخره منها الاعلامي الذي كان يعمل
محررا في الصحيفه المتهمه
[موسيقى]
لكن
التي سيخوضها هاري الذي حرص على الظهور
علنيا في جلسه استماع لمحكمه يخوضها ضد
صحيفه الديلي ميل الشهر الماضي وسيكون
حضوره في المحكمه في يونيو المقبل محطه
اهتمام وسائل اعلام المحليه وعالميه لكن
هذه بدايه الطريق لمحاكمات معقده قد تستمر
اسابيع سيظل فيها هاري عنوانا رئيسيا في
وسائل الاعلام التي يقول انه يرغب بشده في
ان تبتعد عن شؤونه
غضب الامير هاري المكبوت فجر اكبر ازمه في
تاريخ العائله الملكيه الحديث ليصب جاما
غضبه على اقوى الصحف البريطانيه
اسباب تراجعه عن مهامه الملكيه ورحيله الى
كاليفورنيا لصباح العربيه من لندن عروب
عبد الحق
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات